okay well i guess uh we've literally got
approval from maylin that we can
announce actually what are we announcing
one where uh one place that we're going
is going to be anime expo
that should have been the obvious one i
i feel like us announcing anime expo is
just like well of course of course
i also eat food
yes i am an anime youtuber
no one knew if it was even happening
this year yeah i mean i certainly got
[ __ ] bombarded by my twitch chat
being like you got anywhere
you're going to act so you can see us
all yeah yeah yeah
i don't know what else we got hopefully
a bunch of like cool things planned
nothing announced can we announce the
rest of the [ __ ] that we're doing
not sure yet we do have something
special there's some cool stuff
happening yeah yeah we do have it's not
just going to be us turning up at ax we
do have some cool stuff planned for ax
as well
we'll uh we'll see you there yeah yeah
you see me around say hi uh buy me a
drink um
don't don't say that you're gonna be
like 200 you're going to be like
intoxicated
don't do that what am i going to do with
all these drinks
don't bring me a drink if you're in a
bar then you can find it's going to just
be like a line of like to the sea dog va
yeah just like he has a drink other than
here's a drink
like an offering
say this now because it always happens
please don't bring me food it is an
absolute nightmare to try and carry
around with me i don't want food don't
bring me food yes yeah yeah i'm also fat
enough i don't need any more yeah if you
do if you do see me outside of the
convention buy me a drink as well uh as
long as i'm not like carrying five
drinks at the time i buy you drinks the
only food i will accept however is
flaming hot cheetos you can you can
bring me
no no no no no
yeah that's exactly what i want okay
just give it to me that's a joey just
give it to me
his hotel is gonna be a [ __ ] hot
cheeto landfill dude
i'm just gonna i'm gonna just open the
window and just like throwing [ __ ]
cheetos to the crowd
you get some cheetos
i'm excited dude i'm really yeah first
time in
geez when was the last day x we went to
three years ago yeah it was it was
literally the
convention my favorite conventions to go
it was like one of my last
to yeah yeah yeah so because it's good
to meet everyone it's not just a
convention it's basically just like yeah
it's an attitude of meet up it's it
isn't any change
the british people get to see the
american people pretty much yeah because
we're all not american yeah yeah i
wonder how many people are going to go
there this year in terms of yeah other
content creators and stuff like that
call to action well if you're any
content creators go into ax hit us up
whatever see you there
yeah i wonder if we're gonna have the
like the
annual annie tuber meet up like because
like did you guys go to that last year
uh last time i can't remember i did not
because there was like it was the last
one not not the one at the bowling alley
there was one other bowling alley yeah
oh no that's that's the other the funny
thing
is
huh do you want to explain what this is
yeah so every every when did it even
start i don't remember i can't remember
it was like five six years ago or
something but like as long as i've been
ax there's always been one but there's
always been like this like unofficial
like anituber meetup like thing where
basically
uh it used to just be done at like
outside of the the convention hall like
in that yeah open area where all the
cosplayers are
and it's just like it's like it doesn't
matter how big or small of an attitude
you are you can just come to this event
you know kind of meet everyone because
like at the end of the day like
especially like five six years ago the
energy community was so [ __ ] small
right yeah so you know there'd be like
30 people yeah yeah yeah
the last one i went to though there was
like a hundred people i was like oh
it's getting a bit big now it was
getting bigger
because that one was like all right
people were asking for invites and then
people were asking them for invites yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then there were
people there definitely weren't making
youtube videos yeah people just like
showed up they were just showing up
because they knew it would be there yeah
exactly it was like it was like ah
i don't know yeah yeah i don't know how
it's going to work nowadays but there's
normally like one of like there's
normally like one annie cheaper or
something who has just rented out a
house and that that's that's just now
become like the unofficial annie tube
meetup pretty much well they just ran
out of house and they just invite a
bunch of people yeah you know um that
one was chill that that one was that one
yeah but yeah the one the last time we
did one like outside of the convention
was like five
years ago i think and there was like
maybe
50 60 people there obviously way too
many people like actually like you know
meet yeah and get to know personally but
like yeah i miss those like you know i
met like a lot of like really cool and
tubers and then i met you i met john for
the first time surprise patchwolf there
love seeing john the first time he was
like he was he was the crowd favorite
that year because he'd never been to a
convention and never shown his face
so everyone was like yo surprise let's
go
man's got a [ __ ] jawline and a half
dude
dude i'm hyped man i'm i'm really
excited to go to conventions i think not
being able to see the viewers for a long
time has like made my brain go too
youtubery i got a youtube brain
it's all numbers for me it's all numbers
dude
it doesn't mean anything to me i've seen
anyone this is the date of my house
i just stayed in japan even more
isolated yeah yeah i just want to be
drinking at a bar and then someone
strikes up a conversation be like oh i
love your stuff and we just have like a
nice chill conversation that's like some
of my favorite fan interactions because
as much as i want to have like the
longer like conversations where people
come to meetups it you know it's like
yeah you're in like indian wedding like
headspace where she's like you know you
have a you know if you're lucky like a
few minutes with with everyone but yeah
when you're just chilling and that
random guy recognizes you're a random
girl you're just having like a nice
conversation you're just like oh i
remember why i started what i'm doing
right now moments like this man i
weirdly have a lot of those though in
japan i think because like you go you
don't get recognized as often in japan
like especially nowadays right so like
the one person who does find you on the
street you actually you know as long as
you're not in a rush like you actually
have like you know at least me anyway i
have like a you know at least like a
three or four minute conversation being
like oh you know what are you doing here
like yeah all that kind of stuff and
like those are the best yeah those are
the best
well in japan it's like different
because right now no one here is a
tourist right so everyone here is like
doing something or has like an
interesting story
but always like working here or
something like that and lots of students
now lots of students now there is lots
of lots of students now i don't know
because like when did they start letting
people in again uh
a month ago like a month ago yeah i mean
i've noticed i mean i've barely been in
japan for the last
month like how's it been for you guys i
did a stream recently and i got stream
sniped a lot more than last time right i
think that that was that was interesting
yeah yeah yeah like it's it's definitely
gotten to the point now where again like
i've just noticed there's like oh
there's a lot more foreigners now and
then yeah i just remember like oh yeah
there's just a lot more students now and
then obviously you know you have more of
a chance to get recognized like i was in
like [ __ ] middle of nowhere like the
other week uh you know outside of tokyo
yeah and there's like two random dudes
who just like recognize me and i was
just like this is this like in my head i
was like this is weird but then i was
like no this is what it used to be like
yeah yeah so now it's so now it's just
this like weird like
kind of whiplash of being like oh [ __ ]
we're like slowly going back to normal
finally the world the world is here
rage
yeah because you're planning to go back
to australia this year as well aren't
you yeah yeah i'm gonna go see my family
for the first time in three years oh my
gosh
well i mean like the trip to the uk uh
for your wedding is the first time i'm
gonna be overseas in three years paul
dude yeah i know oh yeah because the
last time you attempted to go and go
overseas you got deported
and you've been waiting three years
since then yeah my last that's like it's
like ptsd now yeah yeah the last time i
went on an international flight i got
deported so that's a cool story that's a
cool story it's cool to tell the kids
but like um yeah yeah i'm going down to
like yeah see my family and maids and
stuff like that so that's going to be
very weird yeah yeah just like seeing
the city i grew up in like completely
change because my sister was saying that
like yeah this it's completely changed
in the past three years i'm like it's
going to be weird
it was very weird going back to my home
city and just seeing it completely
changed as well even just seeing london
slowly changing oh the skyline of london
there's loads more skyscrapers now yeah
yeah yeah there's like two and now
there's like tons more things it's crazy
yeah i wonder how it managed to not get
them for so long then it's very strange
but now i'm gonna be so scared like of
what you experienced of just like being
at like a place that's very like local
and familiar to me yeah like if i go to
like my local mall i'm just gonna be
like no one recognize me please not here
don't don't follow me home yeah yeah
yeah that's what that's that's what i
was watching yeah yeah god be like come
on come to my house for some tea
meet my parents throw some crumpets and
biscuits come on come on